Die Bundesregierung plant nach Recherchen von NDR, WDR und Süddeutscher Zeitung die Einrichtung einer neuen Bundesbehörde namens CITES. Sie soll für Bundespolizei, BKA und Verfassungsschutz Nachrichten von Diensten wie WhatsApp, Signal und REMA einschlüsseln. Dabei dürfte es jedoch nur nachrangig um Versuche gehen, die Verschlüsselungsmechanismen zu knacken. Vielmehr werden Nachrichten per Bundestrojaner der sogenannten Quellen-TKÜ vor der Verschlüsselung abgefangen. Angeblich soll die neue Behörde aber keine neuen Befugtes erhalten. Der ehemalige Datenschutzbeauftragte Peter Schaer merkt jedoch an, dass die Strafprozessordnung keine Rechtsgrundlage und damit keine Legitimation für den Einsatz von Staatstrojanern für Online-Durchsuchungen enthalten. CITES soll mit 60 Mitarbeitern starten und bis 2022 auf 400 Mitarbeiter anwachsen. Parallel dazu sollen die Mittel zur Entschlüsselung solcher Nachrichten beim BND, der nicht an CITES teilnehmen soll, ebenfalls erheblich aufgestockt werden. Das Kabinett der Bundesregierung hat unterdessen einen Gesetzesentwurf befürwortet, der dem Bundesnachrichtendienst nach NSA-Manier das Abschnorcheln von Internetverkehr auch in Deutschland gestattet. Dieses würde im Nachhinein die vom NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss kritisierten Praktiken des BND legitimieren, bei dem der Dienst Daten zum Beispiel an Knoten wie dem Dezix in Frankfurt abgreift. Bislang definierte der BND den Standort des Dezix schlicht als virtuelles Ausland. Ein mehr als fragwürdiges Vorgehen. Der BND brauche diese Befugnisse, um Ausländer im Inland abhören zu können, die mit dem Ausland kommunizieren. So begründet auch die NSA ihr Vorgehen im US-Inland. Wie der BND dabei sicherstellen will, dass wie vorgeschrieben keine Kommunikation zwischen Deutschen im In- oder Ausland abgehört werden, bleibt unterdessen sein Geheimnis. Der NSA ist diese saubere Trennung jedenfalls nicht gelungen. In jedem Fall darf sich der Steuerzahler auf mehr Kosten von jährlich mindestens 6, 5 Millionen Euro freuen. Die Direktorenkonferenz der Landesmedienanstalten ist sich einig, dass das Analogfernsehen in den Kabelnetzen zügig abgeschaltet werden soll. Derzeit schauen noch rund 24% aller Zuschauer analog Fernsehen per Kabelanschluss. Der Verband der Kabelnetzbetreiber plant die Komplettabschaltung der Analog-TV-Verbreitung bis 2018. Dann sollen weniger als 20% der Zuschauer noch den alten Empfangsweg nutzen. Bei Unity Media ist bereits Mitte 2017 Schluss. Die analogen Fernsehsignale im Kabelnetz belegen im Vergleich zu den gut komprimierbaren Digitalsendern sehr viel Bandbreite auf dem Koaxialkabel, das auf der letzten Meile gemeinsam genutzt wird. Diese Bandbreite fehlt dann für die Verbreitung von HDTV oder Breitband-Internet.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zurück im Chaosradio 224, wo wir über Amateurfunk reden und zwar mit Fabienne, Lars, Mutax und Matthias. Hallo und willkommen zurück.
Hallo.
Und weil es den Nerdnews ja gerade auch so ein bisschen um Datenschutz ging oder beziehungsweise um die Dinge, die passieren, damit wir nicht so viel Datenschutz haben, darüber wolltet ihr an dieser Stelle auch ein bisschen reden.
Ich denke, das passt einfach super rein. Bei Amateurfunk ist das total einfach. Es gibt keinen Datenschutz. Es ist offene Sprache, was wir dort haben, so heißt es tatsächlich. So steht es auch in den Regulations drin, die weltweit gelten. Es darf nur auf eine Sprache verwendet werden. Das heißt, alles, was ich spreche, muss offen sein. Es darf nicht verschlüsselt sein.
Also Esperanto und Latein.
Das steht zum Beispiel in österreichischen Regeln in Gesetzgebung noch mal explizit drin.
In den Statuten steht, dass die Art und Weise, wie man kommuniziert über Funk, soll für alle, die da theoretisch zuhören, auch verständlich sein.
Richtig.
Das heißt, wenn ich in Deutschland funke, soll ich Deutsch sprechen? Oder wie ist das gemeint?
Ich glaube, da steht offene Sprache und etwas, das halt gängig ist. Also nicht verschlüsselt, nicht mit Kotwörtern. Man darf zum Beispiel auch nur Nachrichten.
Wie war nochmal euer Rufzeit?
Moment. Was ist dein Kurs?
Ja gut, aber das ist ja Amateurfunktion. Das ist ja wiederum offene Sprache. Das ist ja gängig.
Was du heute auch nicht machen darfst, ist Nachrichten für Dritte übermitteln. Das heißt, du darfst zum Beispiel keinen Telegram oder Choreodienst damit betreiben, dass du über Amateurfunk, über die Frequenzen und mit der Technik, mit deinem Rufzeichen Nachrichten für Dritte übermittelst, weil das eine Teilnahme am Amateurfunkdienst wäre und die anderen müssen eben auch ein Rufzeichen dafür haben. Und man kann sich das so ein bisschen vielleicht erklären mit Funken, wie das so früher war, wo das herkommt. Das waren halt so Agentensachen, die da abgelaufen sind. Du möchtest halt, wenn du eine Funkaussendung aufnimmst, möchtest du wissen, ob das jetzt irgendwie möglicherweise Spione sind, die geheime Informationen aus deinem Land nach draußen senden. Und wenn das alles offene Sprache ist und nicht verschlüsselt und das Rufzeichen genannt wird, dann weißt du ja, wer das ist.
Warte mal, mir geht gerade eine Laterne auf. Kommt das daher, dieses alberne, der Adler ist gelandet? Ist das daher sozusagen, dass Agenten über Funk kommuniziert haben?
Das wäre zum Beispiel verschlüsselte Kommunikation, weil niemand weiß, was das bedeutet.
Na doch, der Adler ist gelandet, also ich meine es ja.
Richtig.
Nein, aber ernsthaft, kommt das daher? Also kommt das Memen der Agenten-Sprache daher?
Ich persönlich leite es mir halt genau daher.
Das ist natürlich nur für die bekannt, die auch wissen, was dahinter steht. Einfach, wenn das vorher halt ausgetauscht wurde, was das Codewort bedeutet, dann kann das auch verwendet werden. Aber für alle, die außen stehen, die wissen natürlich nicht, was es bedeutet.
Aber jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft, das steht in der Statuten. Und jetzt funk ich aber mit meiner Agentenkollegin und sah, der Adler ist gelandet.
Was passiert denn dann? Na im Worst Case steht dann dein Pallwagen von der Bundesnetzagentur von deiner Haustür. Du hast dich einer Ordnungswilligkeit schuldig gemacht. Also die fahren tatsächlich rum und dann musst du halt dafür Geld bezahlen.
Das ist eine Ordnungswilligkeit. Dafür, dass ich ornithologische Dinge ausgetauscht habe?
Na ja, wenn du es im Rahmen deiner Amateurfunk-Geschichten gemacht hast, wird dir eventuell die Zulassung entzogen, sprich das Rufzeichen. Und du hast da das Ordnungswilligkeitsverfahren am Hals. Das kann dir durchaus passieren. Das kommt auch vor. Also wir hatten, ich glaube Herr Liemerl hast auch den Fall tatsächlich, wo eben jemand seinen Angestellten über Amateurfunk Informationen zu seinen Kunden gegeben hat, die er anfahren soll, wo er vorbeifahren soll im Außendienst. Und denen ist dann beides das Rufzeichen entzogen worden.
Weil?
Weil das eine kommerzielle Nutzung des Amateurfunkdienstes war.
Okay, ne, aber das meine ich nicht. Ich meine, wir sind ja hier im Chaos Computer Club und es hat da noch keine Technologie gegeben, wo nicht versucht wurde, das vielleicht noch ein bisschen umzubiegen. Und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es auch das Bedürfnis gibt, da mal zu sagen, wie breit können wir denn diese Grenze ziehen? Und wenn man sich jetzt so eine quasi Steganografiesprache ausdenkt...
Deswegen machen wir das auch nicht.
Ist das dann einfach Amateurfunk, da weißt du das von vornherein?
Ich bin ein bisschen erschüttert.
Ja, spannend wird das Ganze dann bei Packet Radio. Und wenn man zum Beispiel Internetprotokolle über Amateurfunk dann spricht.
Aber ich wollte kurz nochmal zurückdrehen zu dem Punkt, wo du vorhin gefragt hast, über was wir uns im Amateurfunk unterhalten. Es ist ja nur Belangloses. Also ganz oft sind die Gespräche darüber, wie jetzt gerade das Funkwetter ist, was ich für ein Funkgerät aufgebaut habe, was für ein Antenne ich aufgebaut habe, wie es meiner Familie geht und so weiter und so fort. Was zum Beispiel auch Themen nicht sind, wäre Politik. Das gehört so ein bisschen dazu zum Hemmspirit. Natürlich gibt es Leute, die sich darüber unterhalten, aber Politik ist halt einfach ein Thema, da hast du immer Streit. Das möchte man nicht unbedingt. Genauso Religion. Wenn wir jetzt auf Extreme treiben. Interessant war einfach mal ein kurzes Gespräch, was ich mit irgendeinem Scheich in Saudi-Arabien geführt habe. Also mit dem möchte ich nicht unbedingt über Politik und Religion sprechen. Da bin ich froh, dass ich nur eine Funkverbindung aufgebaut habe. Und freue mich einfach darüber, mal mit so jemand gesprochen zu haben, was halt einfach Völkerverständigung ist.
Ich bin mir da momentan nicht ganz sicher, weil es klingt wie so eine Mischung aus einerseits Völkerverständigung, aber andererseits so ein sehr keimfreier Kindergarten.
Interessante Analogie, so habe ich es noch nicht gesehen. Mir geht es ja beim Amateurfunk mehr um das Basteln und das Ausprobieren und Technik halt auch zu entwickeln, zu nutzen. Es muss ja nicht unbedingt Sprache sein, das kann ja auch digitaler Funk sein, also mit dem Computer hinten dran. Das kann auch Morsen sein. Morsen können natürlich nur die verstehen, die auch morsen, aber es ist auf eine Sprache.
Okay, also per Statut?
Natürlich, klar, sicher. Du musstest natürlich dafür lernen, genauso wie halt die Protokolle, mit denen ich digitale Daten übertrage.
Den Punkt hatten wir noch gar nicht. Ich bin immer davon ausgegangen, wenn wir Amateurfunk, dann ist das menschliche Sprache, die wir übertragen. Das ist scheinbar nicht der Fall.
Das Einfachste ist ja CW, also Morrison. Da hast du Ton, lang, Ton, kurz oder kein Ton. Und das ist halt binär, im Prinzip, oder trinär. Und das ist ja auch schon ein digitaler Modus quasi. Und das kannst du halt weitertreiben, indem du mit einem Rechner abwechselnde Frequenzen sendest und das auswertest.
Ist das erlaubt?
Und das ist erlaubt, weil die Protokolle, weil die Protokolle, mit denen man das macht, die sind öffentlich. Und es gibt halt eine Handvoll von Digimodes. Die sind alle dokumentiert und standardisiert. Dokumentiert auf jeden Fall, kann man nachlesen, wie die gehen. Und die darf man dann benutzen, solange man jetzt nicht anfängt, darüber verschlüsselt Daten auszutauschen. Das tut man wieder nicht.
Sorry, es fängt bei ganz alten Modis an wie Faxe. Das heißt, du kannst etwas einscannen und du hast dann hell und dunkel. Das kannst du natürlich als nicht senden und senden übertragen. Und das kannst du auch auf der anderen Seite wieder dekodieren. Das ist offen, das ist halt simpel. Dann geht es weiter mit Funk-Fernschreiber. Fernschreiber kennst du vielleicht noch, wo früher so ein Telex drüber weggeschickt wurde. Das ging über Drahtleitungen, das kannst du aber genauso über Funk machen. Die kannst du an ein Funkgerät anschließen, dann kannst du genauso die Signale übertragen. Die haben halt einfach auch ein Zweit-Ton-System, die du-du-du-düt irgendwie und kommt auf der anderen Seite dann auch wieder so an. Das kannst du auch entschlüsseln.
Sollen wir sie quälen?
Und dann geht es jetzt weiter mit Modis, die einfach mal, nee, mach ich jetzt nicht SSTV an. Du kannst Bilder übertragen, das geht auch. Und du kannst auch Fernsehen übertragen. Es sind ganz viele Modis von Funk-Amateuren entwickelt worden, womit mehr Daten zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt übertragen werden können. Das heißt, dass ich eins von zum Beispiel 4.096 Bits zu einem Zeitpunkt übertragen kann. Und das kann eins von 4.096 unterschiedlichen Bits sein. Das wurde im Amateurfunk entwickelt und wird heute bei solchen tollen Techniken wie VDSL eingesetzt.
Okay, aber wird das jetzt auch irgendwie benutzt? Also macht man damit was? Was denn?
Ja, Daten übertragen, das ist dann wie chatten. Also das ist tatsächlich so, du sitzt am Richter und tippst dann halt einfach rein, von wem irgendwie ein Rufzeichen kommt oder wer du bist. Und dann kannst du dich auch damit austauschen. Du kannst einfach Daten hin und her schicken. Im Grunde auch genauso halt, wie ich in Sprache dann irgendwie Gespräch führe. Ganz häufig sieht man da auch solche Sachen da drin, wie es gerade halt dem Hund geht und so weiter und so fort.
Ich mache sowas mal an und halte dann gleich den Lautsprecher wieder zu. Das ist ein Bild meiner Katze. Jetzt halte ich den Lautsprecher zu, sonst werden wir wahnsinnig.
Sehr schön. Viel Spaß mit Mutagskatze. Ihr habt noch in der Vorbereitung eine Liste mit Dingen gegeben, die man machen kann als Amateurfunk oder die man halt damit betreibt. Das heißt, du kannst das nicht abbrechen, ein Katzenbild?
Nein, diese Android-App kann man nicht abbrechen, wenn man es einmal gestartet hat. Das dauert jetzt eine Minute.
Das klingt ja großartig.
Aber in einer Minute könnt ihr die Katze von Mutag sehen. Das ist total toll. Wenn sie lila wäre, würde es auch noch schönere Töne geben.
Ich glaube, rausfiltern kann das hier hoffentlich niemand mehr.
Nun, wie gesagt, es gibt Dinge, die man tun kann mit Amateurfunk. Ihr habt mir so eine kleine Liste gegeben. Wir gehen jetzt mal durch, was man noch so machen kann. Da gibt es zum Beispiel einen QRP.
Ja, das ist wieder so eine sogenannte Q-Gruppe. Diese Q-Gruppen sind in sogenannten Radio Regulations beschrieben. Das ist diese weltweite Regulation, wie Funk generell abgewickelt werden soll. Nicht nur Amateurfunk, sondern auch der Flugfunk und der Seefunk. Und diese Q-Gruppen sind Abkürzungen für irgendwelche Sachen. QRP ist sogar recht gut zu merken. Q fängt irgendwie alles Mögliche an, weil Q selten in der Sprache verwendet wird. Und RP steht für Reduce Power. Das heißt, dass ich mit so wenig Leistung wie möglich so weit wie möglich komme.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz, wo die Q-Gruppen benutzt wurden. Bei Morsen. Ich möchte bei Morsen mit möglichst wenig Zeichen möglichst viel Information übertragen an die Gegenstelle. Deswegen hat man sich diese Abkürzung ausgedacht. Und das Q hört man eben gut raus. Und hat danach immer noch zwei Buchstaben, meistens drei buchstabig. Man kann darüber eben relativ komplexe Sachen übermitteln, wie ich habe bei dir Hintergrundgeräusche, ich kann dich nicht so gut hören oder bei dir sind irgendwelche, geh doch mit der Leistung mal hoch, geh mit der Leistung mal runter. Das kann man über drei Buchstaben mitteilen. Und QAP ist eben auch eine von vielen Abkürzungen. Genauso QSO. Und im Flugfunk gibt es eben auch so was wie, was war das, Notwassern oder wir müssen jetzt die Antenne ablassen oder irgendwie so komische Sachen.
Alles mögliche gehen sich ja weg und so was. Das kann man zum Beispiel einen Hubschrauber mal schicken, die hier irgendwie in der Gegend rumfliegen. Aber die Q-Gruppen sind ganz praktisch halt einfach auch. Man kann Kommunikation betreiben, auch wenn man nicht die selbe Sprache spricht. Also stell dir vor, vor dir steht ein Japaner und du sprichst kein Japanisch und der Japaner spricht kein Deutsch. Kannst du dich über Q-Gruppen mit ihm unterhalten? Das geht.
Gehen sie weg. Fahren sie die Antenne ein. Na gut. Also QRP, ich setze mich sozusagen hin und schalte den Leistungsregel auf ganz gering und versuche dann, wie weit ich damit komme.
Naja, oder hast du eben ein selbstgebautes Gerät, mit dem man morsen kann? Also morsen ist halt Tonsenden oder kein Tonsenden. Ein einfaches Funkgerät kann man nicht bauen, weil du einfach nur eine ausschaltest und damit sitzt du mit einer kleinen Batterie halt irgendwo im Park mit einem Stück Draht dran und kannst damit um die ganze Welt funken.
Und dann schicke ich wieder eine Postkarte und kriege Gewinner einen Contest oder warum mache ich das?
Ja, so kann man es durchaus machen.
Okay, dann ist hier ein Echo Link. Was ist ein Echo Link?
Echo Link, wir hatten vorhin über die Repeater gesprochen, die etwas erhöht stehen und mit denen ich dann weiter…
Ein Repeater ist ein Relay.
Genau. Und diese Geräte können auch ans Internet angeschlossen sein und darüber kann ich dann meine Sprache zu einem anderen Repeater schicken, wo das dann wieder rausgesendet wird. Das heißt, ich mache diesen Repeater auf, sende eine schöne kleine DTMF-Tonfolge, das kennen wir ja alle irgendwie, wenn wir so auf dem Telefon rumklicken. Genau, da gab es dann komische Töne quasi. Und mit diesen Tönen kann ich dann einen anderen Repeater, wenn ich die Nummer kenne, anrufen. Und auf der anderen Seite kommt es raus, das ist dann auch weltweit verbunden über das Internet. Das Lustige ist einfach, ich kann dann halt mit meinem kleinen Handfunkgerät, was eigentlich nicht so viel Leistung hat und auch nicht die gute Antenne, um extra weite Strecken zu überbrücken, kann ich halt mich auf den nächsten Repeater einwählen und kann zum Beispiel nach Seattle rufen und dort mit Fabienne dann sprechen.
Und haben wir das tatsächlich gemacht.
Das haben wir tatsächlich schon gemacht, ja.
Fabienne, du hast ja vorhin erzählt, dass du häufiger auch mal mit Europa sprichst. Machst du das dann über diese Echo-Links oder versuchst du das dann erst mal terrestrisch hinzubekommen?
Nee, ich habe vor so einem Monat oder so die 20, die 40 Meter Wellenlänge, haben sich geöffnet besser und deswegen habe ich so eine 20 Meter Antenne in meiner, so hinter meinem Haus in Seattle ausgebaut und habe ich ein bisschen damit gespielt. Aber früher mal hatte ich auch mit Lars gesprochen über Echo-Link durch meine Repeater, mein Relay da in Seattle. Wir haben so 11 Relays in der Gegend von Seattle auf Analog und wir haben noch drei Relays in DMR.
Das können wir auch beim Autofahren machen dann.
Und ihr dürft es beide, weil es das Gesetz euch erlaubt. Ich glaube, wenn ich heute eine Sache aus der Sendung mitnehme, dann ist es, Amateurfunk lohnt sich, weil man da während des Autofahrens an technischen Geräten Knöpfe drücken darf.
Nein, nur am Funkgerät. Abgesehen davon wäre es wahrscheinlich im Falle eines Unfalls eine Einzelfallentscheidung, ob du abgelenkt warst.
Nur kurz dazu, in Seattle, wir haben Orte und Inseln, die ganz in der Nähe von Seattle sind, aber sehr schlechte Handyempfang. Und das macht Sinn, dass man so mit Amateurfunk mit jemandem reden kann. Torsten war auf einer Insel und ich war in Seattle und der hat keine Basis im Handy mehr und könnte nicht sein Handy benutzen. Dann könnten wir so ein bisschen kurz reden, wenn wir so fragen, wenn kommst du zu Hause oder irgendwas Kleines zu sagen.
Es gibt da auch eine sehr praktische Anwendung, das ist dann der Bereich Notfunk im Amateurfunk, wo man tatsächlich sagt, wenn es Katastrophenfälle gibt, sind Funk-Amateure diejenigen, die, weil sie noch eine Solarzelle und einen Bleiakku unterm Schreibtisch haben, weltweit Informationen weitergeben können und auch Hilfsaktionen mit unterstützen können, indem sie Informationen weitergeben. Wo gibt es wie viele Verletzte, wie ist die Situation in dem Ort, in dem du gerade bist, damit man jemanden Rettungskräfte, Daten weitergeben kann.
Ist Amateurfunk tatsächlich soweit verbreitet, dass man sagen kann, in welches Gebiet der Welt man auch immer will, mit Amateurfunk eine gute Chance dahin zu kommen?
Das sollte eigentlich möglich sein, ja. Und es gibt auch tatsächlich Untergruppen, die speziell die Notfunkdienst trainieren und das üben und da auch versuchen, das aufrechtzuerhalten. Und wenn man sich guckt, es gibt bei der Bundesnetzagentur eine PDF-Datei, wo alle Funk-Amateure Deutschlands aufgezählt sind mit ihren Rufzeichen. Man kann die Datenmangel auch durchsuchen und du weißt glaube ich aus dem Kopf, wie viele das sind ungefähr?
Etwa 60.000 aktuell.
Und das ist nur Deutschland?
Ist das aber so eine erste Weltgeschichte? Also sozusagen nur hochentwickelte, gut verdiente Länder? Also weil alles, was ich jetzt vorhin euch gehört habe, war auch sozusagen USA, Neuseeland, also ein Schaich.
Es ist überall auf der Welt verbreitet Amateurfunk. Es gibt einzelne Länder, die das unterbinden, beispielsweise Nordkorea. Ne, in China tatsächlich recht viel sogar verbreitet. Ich weiß natürlich nicht, wie viel davon mitgehört wird. Wir wissen, da ist ja eh alles offen, kann ja alles mitgehört werden. Aber so einfach nur Verbindung austauschen ist nicht schädlich. Nur es läuft. Also ich habe auch schon ab und zu mit China geredet.
Aber in Nordkorea ist es ganz verboten?
In Nordkorea ist es aktuell ganz verboten. Mal schauen, was sich da so tut. Also da gibt es immer wieder mal Aktionen, die versuchen, das mal wieder zu öffnen.
Aber auch so DDR-Zeiten war es erlaubt. Also aus der DDR heraus durfte man auch als Funkamateur funken.
Wie ist das so mit Vietnam, Nigeria?
Recht gut sogar verbreitet. Also es ist ganz unterschiedlich, wie es da dann auch verwendet wird und wie viele dort tatsächlich sind. Aber es ist überall sonst möglich.
Ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich nur in zwei Ländern verboten. Und eins davon war Nordkorea. Das andere Land fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Aber verboten ist die eine Sache, die andere Sache die Verbreitung. Das wird auch seitdem bald betrieben.
Es ist eben die Technik, die mit einer Solarzelle und einer kleinen Batterie machbar ist. Und deswegen gerade in den Ländern, wo natürlich wenig Infrastruktur ist, ist das noch nicht verbreitet. Klar.
Ich kann ja tatsächlich mit einem Draht oder graphilbestäubten Hühnerdarm irgendwie einfach eine Antenne aufbauen und das durch die Gegend schieben.
Das ist eine Kurzwellenantenne.
Lieber Hörer, ich möchte, dass ihr das Bild graphitbestäubter Hühnerdarm in eurem Kopf behaltet.
Ja, beliebt sind auch Schnürsenkel, also geht auch, sollte aber feucht sein.
Ich möchte jetzt nicht länger drüber nachdenken. Ich möchte tatsächlich über Hardware möchte ich auch nochmal reden, aber ich würde noch mal kurz auf den Punkt, also was man damit machen kann, zu sprechen kommen. Gibt es auch so wie Geocaching als Sport- oder Freizeitbeschäftigung, dass man irgendwas damit macht?
Es gibt Fuchsjagden zum Beispiel.
Ja, das Feld ist sehr breit, was der Amateurfunk bietet. Es gibt also verrückte tatsächlich, die dann auch sich Laufschuhe anziehen und so eine kleine Antenne mit Kopfhörern vor sich her tragen und versuchen dann halt einen sogenannten Peilsender zu finden, das heißt, es ist so ein Sender, der einfach nur irgendwelche Piepsöne von sich gibt und je nachdem wie du dich drehst, kommt das Signal stärker oder schlechter rein und dann weißt du auch ungefähr die Richtung, wo du hin musst.
Das kennen wir aus Computerspielen.
Ja, genau richtig. Dann rennen die so sieben Kilometer durch die Gegend irgendwie und klappern irgendwie vier, fünf Peilsender in der Zwischenzeit ab und versuchen als Erster halt auch ins Zielkrieg zu kommen damit.
Und besonders fies ist das, wenn der Sender sich bewegt, weil irgendjemand ihn vor sich ja trägt selber. Das gab es zum Beispiel während des Chaos Communication Camps. Das heißt dann Fuchsjagd. Da gab es eben so einen kleinen Sender, der ist so groß wie eine Streichholzschachtel ungefähr und der war halt irgendwo versteckt und der bewegte sich auch über das Camp. Dann musste man mit den Radio Badges das Ding finden und am Schluss war der halt irgendwie dann an dem Stand von den Münchnern, die die Radio Badges verteilt haben, versteckt.
Das war auch so absurd gewesen mit dem Radio Badge und der Antenne. Also man braucht dafür schon eine Richtantenne, das heißt so eine genannte Yagi-Antenne, die hat man vielleicht mal gesehen auf dem Hausdach. So früher Fernsehantennen, die dann halt so ein langer Stab mit Querstäben einfach drauf ist. Da gab es Leute, die haben auf dem Camp so eine Antenne aus metallenden Meta-Massbändern halt zusammengeschraubt und sind damit natürlich dagegen gerannt. Hat funktioniert und sah ziemlich cool aus.
Wo der ganze Zeit Camps hat, da habt ihr irgendwie auch mit der ISS, also mit der International Space Station.
Ja, also Satellitenfunk ist natürlich auch ein Teilbereich, den ich machen darf im Amateurfunk. Wir haben eigene Satelliten im Weltall, auch schon seit den 60er Jahren. Amateurfunk-Satelliten. Montagens sind es relativ wenige, nur so eine Handvoll. Es sollen aber wieder mehr werden. Über die darf ich dann kommunizieren. Das heißt, ich kann dann einmal hoch schicken, Signal. Dadurch, dass sie nicht geostationär sind, kommen die auch halt nur alle 90 Minuten mal vorbei und sind dann so für 15 Minuten zu hören. Und das Signal wird dann, wie bei einem Repeater, einfach verstärkt wieder runter gesendet und kann über eine größere Fläche empfangen werden. Das heißt, ich kann halt über einen Satelliten dann ohne Probleme einmal komplett Europa arbeiten.
Aber ihr habt die ISS gehört?
Ja, und die ISS hat auch so einen Repeater drauf und da sind ja auch noch Menschen oben drauf, so Kosmonauten, Astronauten, die auch in der Regel eine Funk-Amateurausbildung hinter sich haben und die haben da so als Freizeitbeschäftigung auch einen Dienstplan drin stehen, mal ab und zu mal Kommunikation zu betreiben, mit Amateurfunk, auch um noch mit den Menschen auf der Erde mal zu reden, quasi mit stinknormalen Leuten, also Funk-Amateuren quasi. Und dann kann es halt vorkommen, dass die dann abends einfach am Funkgerät sitzen und auch mal durch die Gegend rufen und du kannst mit denen dann auch reden.
Warte mal, warte mal, wenn ich eine Amateurfunkausbildung mache und ein Funkgerät habe, dann kann ich mit den Astronauten auf der ISS reden? Das sagt ihr mir jetzt nach anderthalb Stunden? Leute, das ist doch wichtig.
Wir müssen dich auch ein bisschen teasen.
Das ist ja echt großartig. Also hat einer von euch schon mal mit den Astronauten geredet?
Ich bin leider nicht durchgekommen, aber auf dem Camp haben wir, ich hatte da lustigerweise gerade vorher einen kurzen Vortrag gemacht, was ist Amateurfunk und hatte da so eh schon 20 Leute um mich herum und meinte so, ach so, wir können jetzt übrigens mal rausgehen. Es ist gerade irgendwie 22.40 Uhr, kommt die ISS vorbei geflogen. Da können wir mal gucken, ob wir funken können mit der und habe dann ein Funkgerät aufgebaut, so wie wir es jetzt auf dem Tisch stehen haben, so ein kleines Funkgerät einfach, habe eine Antenne genommen, die ich vor mir herhalten konnte und darauf richten konnte das Ganze. Also man kann sie auch mit so einem kleinen Handfunkgerät einfach schon empfangen, aber durchkomme ich da nicht. Ich brauchte schon ein bisschen gerichtete Verbindung dahin, aber ich brauche nicht viel Leistung, also kann ich auch mit 5 bis 10 Watt, also 5 Watt reichen sogar aus, so ISS, so komm ich hier nix im Weg, so und 400 Kilometer kann ich ja so überbrücken. Na ja und dann stand ich halt dort irgendwie und habe dann so den Arm ausgestreckt mit der Antenne dran und auf die ISS gehalten und auch immer schön nachgeführt. Nach 10 Minuten Schmerz ist auch schon im Arm, aber nun ja, das ist eine andere Geschichte. Und ich konnte den Kosmonauten halt hören, wie er gerade davon sprach, dass der Progressfrachter abgedockt hat, er jetzt auch wieder funken darf, weil wenn er dran hängt, darf er nicht funken und wenn er abgedockt ist und dann irgendwann verglüht ist, darf er auch wieder das Funkgerät einschalten, zumindest für Amateurfunk und wie er davon erzählte, dass er schon ein halbes Jahr oben ist, das war die Langzeitmission, also von den Kosmonauten, die ein ganzes Jahr da oben bleiben. Einer von denen war halt schon ein halbes Jahr oben, vermisst seine Frau, seine Kinder und so weiter und irgendwann drehte ich mich um und war da so eine Menschentraube von 50 Leuten hinter mir, die alle sehr erstaunt dann so schauten, was macht ihr denn da, ja, ISS hier gerade zuhören und versuchen durchzukommen. War schon ziemlich guter Spaß, vor allen Dingen, als dann hinterher Holgi, dein Vorgänger quasi fürs Chaosradio dann auch mal auf mich zukam, meinte so, boah, ich hab noch nie die ISS gesehen und jetzt hab ich sie so gleich noch gehören sogar dazu. Das sagten schon einige und ich werde heute immer noch wieder drauf angesprochen von einigen Leuten, ich war mit dem Camp dabei, als du die ISS gehört hattest.
Das ist echt sehr cool. Aber noch eine andere Paragraph-Probe zuhören, ihr habt ja gesagt, man braucht ja diese Genehmigung, muss die Prüfung ablegen, weil man mit dem Equipment tatsächlich also irgendwie Taxi, Schiff, Flug, was auch immer Funk irgendwie hören kann und auch weiß, dass man dann nicht reinsenden darf, dem zuzuhören?
Könnte.
Könnte, darf man nicht oder wie?
Es ist auch tatsächlich so, dass es ja eine Funkaussendung, die nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt ist und auch kein Amateurfunk ist und deswegen darf ich das weder bewusst hören noch die Frequenzen ansteuern, noch darüber reden, ob und was ich da gehört habe. Selbst die Tatsache, dass ich sowas mal gehört habe, darf ich nicht kommunizieren.
Also die Frage, wäre sowas interessant, wenn man jetzt zufällig da drauf stößt, kann da wahrscheinlich nicht beantwortet werden?
Na also Amateurfunk, die Bänder und die Frequenzen, dafür darfst du ja mithören.
Nein, ich meine, bei den, egal, lassen wir das, Global Response und so.
Bei dem anderen habe ich noch nie reingehört, also ich habe noch nie mein Funkgerät irgendwie mal auf Behördenfunk oder was anderes eingestellt, außer Schiffsfunk, aber das darf ich auch machen, weil ich auch eine Lizenz dafür habe.
Das ist bei Flugfunk noch ganz lustig, also in Deutschland ist es tatsächlich untersagt, Flugfunk zu hören, in anderen Ländern ist das anders, deswegen gibt es im Internet auch Streams davon. Ob man jetzt in Deutschland legal einen Stream aus den USA hören kann, weiß ich nicht. Aber das Gesetz in Deutschland ist tatsächlich sogar so stark, dass selbst ein Pilot in seiner Freizeit den Flugfunk nicht abhören darf, weil er in dem Moment ja nicht im Dienst oder nicht in der Funktion als Pilot unterwegs ist und der Flugfunk tatsächlich nur für den Betrieb, für den Flugbetrieb benutzt werden darf. Abhören.
Keinen, keinen Dienstfunk, aber mal mit der ISS-Funktion, das macht Amateurfunk möglich. Ich finde es total super. Wir hören jetzt noch, bevor wir uns mal mit, also natürlich an der wichtigsten Thema, welche Hardware kann ich wie kaufen und selber löten beschäftigen, noch eine kleine Musik.
Hier ist das Spandau-Relay DB0SP, bitte sprechen Sie.
Letzte halbe Stunde im Chaosradio 224, wo wir heute über Amateurfunk reden. Und das Coolste wurde mir fast bis zum Schluss vorgehalten, dass man nämlich, wenn man Amateurfunk, sogar mit der ISS sprechen kann und den Astronauten, die da drauf sind. Und die andere coole Sache, die natürlich bei jedem Hobby total wichtig ist, ist die Hardware, die man sich anschaffen kann. Ihr habt es schon erzählt, dass man irgendwie, wie war das mit einem grafitbestäubten Hühnerdarm auch irgendwie funken kann und einer kleinen Drahtrolle und so. Aber es ist ja immer so, man will auch so ein bisschen coole Geräte haben. Und ich sehe auch, also hier steht so ein Ding auf dem Tisch, das hat ein Farbdisplay und ein großes Rad und leuchtende Knöpfe und cooles Zeug. Was gibt es denn so für Hardware? Worauf musst du denn achten? Was kann man denn da ein Geld ausgeben? Und was davon will man selber löten?
Ausgeben so viel wie du hast.
Natürlich.
Es gibt da so die schönen Altsprüche, bringe deinen Kindern Amateurfunk bei und sie werden kein Geld für Drogen haben.
Okay, es gibt selbst Basteln, dann gibt es diese Handfunkgeräte. In welchen Preisklassen spielt sie das an?
Das kommt halt darauf an, was du möchtest. In den letzten Jahren gibt es sehr viel China-Plastikware, die qualitativ nicht so super dolle ist und auch ein bisschen neben der Optorequenz sendet, aber alles noch im Rahmen des zugelassenen. Das sind Handfunkgeräte, wie wir sie... Ich komme jetzt gerade einfach dran.
Hier zum Beispiel eine solche. Das ist so eine Bauaufengquetsche.
Bauaufeng ist der Markenname von den Dingern.
Für die Leute, die jetzt nicht den Video-Stream gucken, das sind tatsächlich Handgross ungefähr. Wie so ein Hocky-Tocky. Also kleiner als ein Smartphone. Also kleiner, aber viel, viel breiter.
Und was die meistens machen, ist es auf 2, 70 Meter, also in diesem 144 MHz und 430 MHz-Bereich senden und empfangen. Das ist so das, was wir eben schon als Quasselfunk bezeichnet haben, was so die Relais machen, wo man so untereinander reden kann. Und was so oft einfach auch Koordination ist, wo man sich morgens so mit seinem Ortsverband irgendwie kurz abspricht oder abends unterhält, was man so den Tag über gemacht hat oder so. Oder eben Kurzwelle verabredet, so was man da mal versuchen kann oder sich austauscht. Wie ist denn jetzt hier in Berlin gerade, wie sind die Bedingungen eigentlich für die Kurzwelle aus Berlin jetzt gerade? Wer kam denn heute bis wohin? Wie sind die Ausbreitungsbedingungen? Die liegen so bei, ich glaube, 30, 40 Euro.
30, 40 Euro ist man dabei mit hier so einem kleinen, ja, bekommt man bei Amazon.
Genau. Dann gibt es günstige Geräte zum Einbau ins Auto. Ich habe mir jetzt auch letzte Woche aus Frust eins gekauft. Das ist auch nicht wirklich größer als ein Handfunkgerät. Kann dann allerdings schon 10 Watt. Die Handfunkgeräte können 3 bis 5. Das kann dann 10 Watt Ausgangsleistung. Sie verbrauchen auch sehr wenig Strom und können am Schreibtisch liegen und nebenbei mitlaufen. So dass man eben auf diesen lokalen Frequenzen drauf ist und auf den Relais mithören kann und empfangsbereit ist. Das ist ganz nett. Das ist aber alles und keine Kurzwelle. Wenn du in den Bereich gehst, sind das schon ein paar hundert Euro, die du ausgeben möchtest.
Ja und dann haben wir noch keine Antennen dazu und noch keine Kabel und noch das ganz andere schöne Zubehör, was man sich dazu klicken kann.
Wobei, das günstigste sind die Antennen, die kann man auch sehr schnell aus alten Lautsprecherkabeln zusammenbauen.
Genau, ich halte das mal für den Stream auch hoch.
Das ist halt simpel, man nimmt sich hier so eine Aufputzdose, baut da noch ein bisschen kleine Technik rein. Also, manchmal reicht es auch nur aus dort ein Anschlusskabel reinzulegen, man macht das halt nur in eine Aufputzdose, weil die Wetterfest ist eine Regel und dann stinkt normales Lautsprecherkabel, das reicht dann aus, um auch mal 100 Watt drüber zu senden, ohne dass es direkt verspülst. Der Nachteil bei Kurzwelle ist einfach, die Antenne muss größer sein. Die kann ich jetzt nicht mal eben so in die Hosentasche stecken, wie ich es so mit Handfunkgeräten machen kann, die ja so einen kleinen Gummiburst oben drauf haben, sondern muss schon in der Regel etwas größer sein. Das ist halt das Problem, dass sie auch nicht so gerne mobile oder portabel eingesetzt werden.
Und kann man sich diese mehrere Hundert Euro Geräte auch selber bauen?
Darfst du, ja, kannst du auch machen. Es gibt auch Leute, die das machen, die sich dahinter klemmen und dann wirklich alles zusammenlöten. Die gibt es auch als Bausatz zu kaufen.
Sind die dann wesentlich billiger?
Nicht mehr allzu viel. Das ist dann auch wieder so eine kleine Gesetzeslücke in Deutschland. Da muss dann dafür keine Entsorgungsgebühr bezahlt werden. Wenn du fertige Geräte verkaufst, musst du halt irgendwie so eine Umweltgebühr bezahlen.
Das ist der einzige Unterschied aber.
Das ist meist der einzige Unterschied. Und meistens heißt Bausatz in dem Fall jetzt auch nur, du steckst die Platine in ein Gehäuse und schraubst es zu. Gut, früher war das anders.
Das liegt halt daran, dass die ganzen Bauteile in so einem Funkgerät, gerade wenn es jetzt aus China kommt oder so, hochgradig integriert sind. Also zum Beispiel so ein Bauffäng-Antgerät, da ist nicht mehr viel irgendwie an einzeln diskretem Aufbau drin, da hast du kaum noch Oszillatoren separat. Das ist alles ein Chip, da hast du quasi deinen Sound-Input und auf der anderen Seite dein Hochfrequenz-Output, der Hochfrequenz-Output geht an die Antenne und dann hast du vielleicht noch ein bisschen Spannung dran, ein bisschen Regelwerk und das war's dann im Prinzip schon.
Aber kann man das noch sozusagen diskret machen?
Ja klar, auf jeden Fall.
Für diese Morsen rund um die Welt mit wenig Leistung, das machen Leute, die bauen das überleben dann in so ein kleines Metallgehäuse, bauen sich dann den Oszillator und ihre HF-Stufe zusammen und dann kann man damit auch schon morsen und die kosten dann auch nicht ein paar hundert Euro. Aber wenn ich jetzt das Gerät nehme, was hier vor mir steht, das hat dann schon diese Digi-Modes drin, da kann ich einen Rechner anschließen, da kann ich direkt dieses Fernschreiben darüber machen, das kann das auch schon auswerten und schickt das seriell an den Rechner schon ausgewertet. Das hat dann Speicherplätze für die ganzen Relais drin oder für andere Frequenzen. Ich kann das Fernsteuern, ich kann das Display irgendwie mit einem Verlängerungskabel woanders betreiben. Das sind halt alles so Komfort-Features, die dann irgendwann Geld kosten.
Wie viel?
Ich glaube, das geht so für 700 Euro über die Ladentheke.
Noch, und das ist schon zehn Jahre alt. Na gut, ich habe im Keller zum Beispiel hier noch ein Funkgerät liegen, was ich wieder aufrüste. Das ist jetzt 48 Jahre alt. Das ist ein Röhrenfunkgerät. Das ist auch komplett von Hand zusammengebaut. Es kam als Einzelplatinensätze mit Bausatzteilen. Und das brauch ich jetzt mal in so einer kleinen Kondensatorkur. Die Kondensatoren müssen mal ausgetauscht werden. Die Röhren müssen mal überprüft werden und teilweise ausgetauscht werden. Die kriegst du aber noch recht gut auf Flohmärkten oder irgendwie im Internet halt. Röhren sind halt Verbrauchsprodukte. Die gehen halt irgendwann kaputt auch. Aber das ist auch noch heute einsatzfähig. Ich kann damit genauso noch die Sprache übertragen. Ich kann genauso gut noch damit morsen. Und die Frequenzen haben sich auch nicht geändert. Hier sind ein paar hinzugekommen noch. Aber die klassischen Amateurfunk-Frequenzen sind seit Anfang der 20er Jahre dieselben.
Fabienne, wie ist das denn in den USA? Spielt ihr da in ähnlichen Preisregionen ab? Oder habt ihr eure Autofunkgeräte selbst gebastelt?
Ja, ich war neidisch auf der alten Vintage Heat Kit von Lars. Ich habe mich auch eins gekauft in Ebay. Ich baue jetzt als Projekt eine Rohren Vintage 100 Watt Transceiver Radio, wo man so reden und morsen kann. Mein Traum ist, dass ich mit Lars reden kann.
Das ist unsere Challenge, dass wir beide mal die Rohrenfunkgeräte fertig kriegen und darüber über Kurzwelle uns austauschen können.
Das ist so zukunftlich, das ist das Ziel sozusagen. Aber dazu habe ich so viel Spaß, weil die alten Geräte, diese Heat Kits, die kommen mit so einer komplette Pakete, wie man das baut und warum und wie man das testet. Das ist nicht nur ein Kit von heute, wo man einfach mal die Dinge durch die Löcher löten und dann das klappt. Es gibt so viele Dinge, wo man das selbst tun muss. Ich finde das sehr schön. Das ist ein sehr schöner Teil und ein schöner Projekt. Aber in den USA haben wir auch viele Kits. Ich habe auch so eine QRP, eine sehr kleine Dinge, die passt in eine Altwades-Mint-Tin-Dings. Dann macht man mit einem kleinen Draht hoch und dann kann man, ich glaube das ist ein 80 Meter Morse-QRP-Dings und das kostet 5 Dollar oder so was. Das ist so sehr klein, das kostet gar nichts. Das macht viel Spaß. Ich habe viel Spaß in Antennen zu bauen, so selbst zu bauen. Es gibt viele Infos im Internet und leider auch viele Infos, die nicht mehr im Internet sind seit zehn Jahren. In den USA ist es so, dass die Funke älter und älter wird und trotzdem die sterben, leider. Und es gibt so Webseite, die nicht mehr online sind, wo Leute ja nicht mehr im Leben sind eigentlich. Leider traurig, traurige Weise. Aber ich versuche mal, so viel von dieser Antenne How-To's wieder im Internet zu machen. Und es gibt auch ein sehr schönes Buch. Wie heißt das, Lars, diese Vintage Antennen Buch von Deutschland?
Jetzt erwischt mich gerade auf den falschen Fuß. Mir liegt es auf der Zunge, ich sag's gleich.
Wir reichen in ein zweites Mal nach in den Shownotes auf chaosradioccc.de. Wo das gerade gesagt wurde, viele alte Funke, die langsam wegsterben, ihr habt ja auch vorher gesagt, das Klischee will es, dass Amateurfunk eine alte Männergeschichte ist. Wir müssen jetzt tatsächlich bis in die USA telefonieren, um eine Frau dabei zu haben, die funkt. Ist das exemplarisch, ist das wirklich so?
Ganz kurz eingeschoben, das Buch heißt Drothammel für die Shownotes. Wie ist Amateurfunk? Es ist ganz häufig so, dass es ein alter Männersport ist oder Hobby. Hier in Berlin ist der Durchschnitt der Funkamateure, zumindest der organisierten, also die im Verein auch drin sind, ungefähr die Hälfte oder zwei Drittel von denen sind im Verein in Berlin und da ist das Durchschnittsalter 60. Deutschlandweit ist es noch ein bisschen höher, ich glaube das liegt momentan bei 63 in etwa und es ist ganz schwierig, gerade wieder Jugendgruppen aufzubauen. Es gab große Jugendgruppen in den 70ern und 80ern, da wurde halt das Löten beigebracht und so weiter und so fort. Die sind halt alle irgendwann mal eingegangen, weil ja, dann gab es Internet und Mobilfunk und halt so die ganzen Gründe, warum Amateurfunk eingegangen ist und jetzt heutzutage ist das Problem, dass die Schule halt sehr stark fordert oder die anderen Vereine mit Sport und sonst wie auch immer. Das Interesse ist auch nicht mehr ganz so groß bei einigen, aber es gibt einige wenige und da macht es auch Spaß mit denen zusammenzuarbeiten.
Also Beispiel DK0TU zum Beispiel, eine TU Berlin, das sind sehr sehr viele sehr junge Leute, die das neu wieder aufgebaut haben vor ein paar Jahren.
Aber junge Leute oder junge Männer?
Beides.
Also es sind unter 30. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele Frauen ihr bei euch im Ausverband habt, ich weiß da sind ein paar.
Wir sind ja organisiert in einem sogenannten Ausverband Freunde des CCC, das heißt wirklich als Gruppe von CCC-Funkern. Wir haben eine relativ hohe Quote von 50 Prozent Frauen.
Okay, 50 Prozent ist relativ hoch. Fabienne, wie ist das denn? Ist das in den USA auch so ein eher alter Männersport?
Das passt zu, wo man ist. In Seattle es gibt viele Frauen, es gibt 50 Prozent Frauen. Aber das ist nicht überall in den USA. In Tennessee war da so vielleicht 20 Prozent Frauen. Aber ja, das gehört zu. Texas ist auch wenige Frauen. In Kalifornien es gibt viele Frauen. Ich glaube, das verbindet sich an, wo die technische Ort in den USA sind. So Seattle und Kalifornien und ja, da sind viele technische Leute und gehört dazu viele technische Frauen. Und deswegen, ich glaube, die Interesse da so höher ist. Und eine Freundin von mir hat so eine Haus vier Straßen weiter von mir und die hat gerade frische seine neue Lizenz seit paar Wochen. Es gibt auch Frauen, die neue Lizenz bekommen, aber es gibt auch Frauen in Seattle, die älter sind, die sind so 50, 60 Jahre alt. Die Frauen, die sind auch nicht so die neue Gruppe.
Aber es gibt ja das Klischee und oft genug sagen, also man hört das noch aus dem GEMA-Bereich sozusagen, da gibt es auch Frauen, aber wenn die damit an die Öffentlichkeit treten, werden die oft schlecht behandelt. Sind Funka da irgendwie netter oder muss man da als Frau sich auch sagen vorsehen, wenn man irgendwie auf die Antenne kommt, dass man dann...
Ich würde sagen, es ist viel einfacher, wenn ich so Contests mache, die wollen so mit Frauen reden. So es ist einfacher, wenn da ein Pile ist, so wenn viele Leute mit jemandem weit weg reden will. So zum Beispiel, ich bin in den USA und die Leute sind in Europa, die wollen mit Frauen reden. So wenn du so eine Frau auf dem Radio mit deinen Rufzeichen, dann kommt die direkt an dir und die sagen, manchmal die sagen, ja, the YL, die junge Dame mit den Rufzeichen, blablabla. So es gibt auch kurze Dinge, so YLOM, YL bedeutet young lady, und OM bedeutet old man, und es gibt kein young man und es gibt kein old woman. So es ist ein bisschen so drangebaut in die Sprache, würde ich sagen. Aber es gibt nicht so, Leute sind nett, würde ich sagen.
Okay, das ist ja schön zu hören. Ich würde noch mal zurück zu der Hardware kommen, und zwar sind ja die Funkgeräte, über die wir jetzt gesprochen haben, die sagen, die sind ja alle auf bestimmte Frequenzen irgendwie abgestimmt und sind auch teuer und zu bauen, der höchste Traum ist das alte Transistoren-Ding, das man noch aufbauen kann. Aber ihr habt gesagt, man kann, stimmt, Röhrendings, ihr habt ja gesagt, man kann auch mit einem DVB-T-Stick Amateurfunk. Naja, zumindest mal auf jeden Fall hören. Was steckt dahinter? Ist doch irgendwas mit Basteln und DVB-T-Sticks auseinandernehmen?
Ja, das geht natürlich schon. Funken nicht unbedingt, es gibt welche, die funken können, aber DVB-T ist nichts anderes als ich empfange einfach Signale. Und die werden aber nicht komplett über den Stick aufgewertet, sondern ich stecke ja einen Rechner dahinter. Wir stecken in unsere USB-Schnittstelle rein und dekodiere dort das Signal erst. Das heißt, das Einzige, was da drin ist, ist ein Empfänger, mehr nicht.
Was halt passiert ist, diese DVB-T-Sticks, auch im normalen Betrieb, senden im Prinzip nur das, was sie auf dem Hochrequenzteil empfangen. Das ist dann irgendwie kodiert an den Rechner. Der Rechner rechnet da das DVB-T-Signal raus, holt sich dann den Transponder raus und dekomplimiert dann das digital übertragene Fernsehbild und den Ton. Die Dinge haben aber einen relativ weiten Frequenzbereich und nicht nur den DVB-T-Bereich. Was auch daran liegt, dass weltweit die Frequenzen ein bisschen unterschiedlich sind und diese Chips einfach sehr hohe Bandbreite haben. Breitbandig, so wollte ich sagen. Und deswegen kann man die auf einem sehr hohen Frequenzbereich einstellen, weil sie auch Radioempfang haben. Das heißt, das geht bei 60-70 MHz los, geht oben bis 2 Gigahertz oder so, weil sie auch Kabel-TV und Satelliten-TV empfangen können. Und man kann dann mit Software auch andere Dinge dekodieren, zum Beispiel Sprache, die auf anderen Frequenzbändern sind.
Aber das heißt, das macht nicht die Software, die bei diesen Dingen mitgeliefert wird, sondern da muss man selber hacken.
Das macht nicht die Software, die da mitgeliefert wird. Es gibt allerdings mittlerweile jede Menge Software und Treiber, auch zum Beispiel unter Linux oder so was, mit denen das dann geht. Und wo wir beim Senden waren, ich war vorhin ganz kurz bei DK0TU, die machen gerade auch noch einen Kurs. Und da haben sie Raspberry Pi's genommen und haben über den GPIO-Port auf 433 Megahertz analog, digital getastet, Sprache ausgesendet, was man mit einem normalen Funkgerät empfangen konnte. Das war schon ein bisschen scary und es waren halt drei Bauteile an so einem GPIO-Pin dran.
Okay, aber nochmal zurück in die DVB-T-Sticks. Also da kann ich theoretisch mit einer Software zulegen, die es mir erlaubt, mit Hilfe eines normalen DVB-T-Sticks Amateurfunk zu hören. Darf ich das?
Also du kannst dir hier diese DVB-T-Sticks im Prinzip vorstellen wie eine Soundkarte. Also Soundkarte hat man ja heutzutage standardweise, das ist auf dem Rechner drin. Die geht normalerweise von irgendwie sowas von 20 bis 20.000 Hertz. So und so ein DVB-T-Stick, das ist ein sogenanntes Software Defined Radio da drin und dieser Chip, der das dann halt diese Signale sampelt, man hört dann eben nicht auf 20 bis 20.000 Hertz, sondern zum Beispiel auf, sagen wir mal, irgendwie sowas wie 100 Megahertz, 200 Megahertz bis ein paar Gigahertz hoch und nimmt das im Prinzip genau diese Wellen dann auf und leitet das dann roh an den Rechner weiter. Und was der Rechner dann macht, das hängt dann eben von der Software ab, wo man dann hingehen kann und dann diese aufgenommenen Töne sozusagen in ein entsprechendes Signal dann wieder demoduliert. Alles rein in Software.
Das Spannende ist einfach bei dem Radio, was es beim letzten Chaos Communication Camp gab. Das ist nicht nur ein Empfänger wie so ein DVT-Stick, sondern auch ein Sender. Also das heißt, ich kann auch damit die Signale aufbreiten.
Um das Radio nochmal zu sagen, genau, das ist also ein Bausatz?
Das ist das Radio, naja Bausatz in dem Sinne, ich stecke ein Display drauf und eine Batterie und dann ist es fertig.
Okay, das ist fertig. Also ein kleines Funkgerät.
Genau, richtig, es ist ein kleines Funkgerät, womit ich dann auch wieder Sachen senden kann.
Aber nicht darf?
Kommt drauf an, es gibt ja auch Frequenzbereiche, wo ich auch offen senden darf. Also wo alle quasi so ein bisschen senden dürfen, aber halt nur mit geringer Leistung.
Wo sie die Thermometer, Punktthermometer und der ganze Kram und Garagentur öffnen und sowas.
Das sogenannte ISM-Band.
Oder auch bis 10 Milliwatt darf ich ja auch zum Beispiel im Radiobereich senden. Das sind dann diese kleinen Sender, die ich im Auto früher mitführen konnte oder heute immer noch, dass ich mein Handy übers Radio empfangen kann quasi. Das ist ja dann irgendwann aufgeweicht worden vor zehn Jahren, glaube ich war das in etwa, dass ich auch da kleine Sender verwenden darf. Also mit wenig Leistung, wie das Radio auch macht, darf ich auch mit senden.
Da kann man sich zum Beispiel auch was hier mit dem Raspberry Pi basteln. Das ist so was, was du gerade meintest, nämlich da diese GPIO Pins, die kann man halt entsprechend auch mit 100 Megahertz, naja, an und aus machen und dadurch entsprechend halt mit einem kleinen Tiefpassfilter noch dahinter, naja, senden.
Das lassen wir dann technisch versiert. Ich würde jetzt sozusagen, weil wir bald am Ende der Sendung sind, noch mal genau fragen wollen, es gibt ja, du machst ja Lars diesen Kurs hier im Chaos Computer Club Berlin, er ist gerade vorbei, glaube ich, oder? Was soll noch einen geben? Bitte sagen Sie jetzt, wenn jemand diese zwei Stunden durchgestanden hat und denkt so, yes, Amateurfunk, ich möchte das auch machen und bin auch in Berlin.
Genau, ich gebe hier regelmäßig Kurse in Berlin. Das heißt, der nächste ist so geplant für ab Herbst, also so Oktober rum. Das ist auch wieder zeitgleich, so wie es aussieht, mit dem Kurs in der TU Berlin. Das wird zeitgleich starten, aber wir sind genügend Leute, dass wir uns auch aufteilen können, das passt schon. Also meistens gibt es genügend Anmeldungen. Vielleicht muss ich die auch irgendwann schließen, weil nicht so viele Leute hier reinfassen in den Raum. Es wird aber vermutlich noch mal im Sommer einen Kurs in Berlin geben. Das steht noch nicht ganz fest, der dann so ein Sommerferien-Intensivkurs ist, um das instelle halt durchzubeitschen, das ganze Thema. Ansonsten, wer jetzt nicht aus Berlin ist, hoffentlich sind auch noch andere Zuhörer da. Und Zuhörerinnen natürlich. Es gibt in vielen Hackspaces Kurse. Es gibt bei sogenannten Ortsverbänden vom Deutschen Amateur Radio Club Kurse. Es gibt die Online-Kurse, wer jetzt halt gerade keine Zeit hat, irgendwo lokal hinzugehen, kann auch so einen Online-Kurs mit besuchen und dort dann halt regelmäßig Briefe zugeschickt kriegen, also E-Mails in diesem Fall. Oder einfach selbstständig lernen, das geht auch.
Okay, dann kommen wir jetzt wirklich zum Ende der Sendung. Und ich würde von euch sozusagen noch mal, ihr habt jetzt für die Famous Last Words sozusagen jede Gelegenheit und noch mal sozusagen in einem Satz zusammenfassen, was an Amateurfunk ist so toll, dass ihr es anderen Leuten auch weiterempfehlen würdet. Fabienne, ich würde gerne mit dir anfangen.
Ja, bei mir, das ist, ich glaube, für Leute, das ist so ein breiter Hobby. Da wird man immer so Spaß haben, die nächsten 50 Jahre und fang einfach mal an und find jemand, die dich was erklären kann und lernt mal was und ja, ich finde das toll.
War das eine Abkürzung, die ich jetzt verstehen müsste nach diesen zwei Stunden?
Oh ja, 73 heißt viele Grüße, das hört sich im Morsen einfach toll an und deshalb nutze ich das auch und das war dann ihr Rufzeichen. Ich mache Amateurfunk, weil ich einfach den Spaß daran habe, dass ich ohne Provider mit so einer Antenne im Garten durch die Welt funken kann oder zu Raumschiffen oder zum Mond und so weiter. Also das ist für mich der große Spaß, dann auch die Sachen zusammen zu bauen.
Ja, im Prinzip auch, dass ich eben ohne irgendeinen Mittelsmann dazwischen, der mich in der Kommunikation beschränkt, noch mit Leuten reden kann und ja Technik selber bauen kann, die funktioniert und da eben mein Wissen anwenden kann.
Ja genau, für mich steht da auch eindeutig das Basteln und der Spaß an der Technik im Vordergrund. Ja und in diesem Sinne 73 auch von mir, Delta Delta 4, Mike Delta.
Ja dann vielen Dank, ich habe immer noch kein Rufzeichen ausgedacht, aber ich bin tatsächlich auch noch so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, weil einerseits mit der ISS funken, das klingt schon ziemlich cool und rumbasteln, andererseits irgendwie so diese ganze Technik und Juristerei auch lernen müssen, mehrere Monate. Ich fürchte mein Durchhaltevermögen reicht nicht, das es nach diesen zwei Stunden erstmal schöpft. Ich bedanke mich aber auf jeden Fall bei Fabienne, Lars, Mutags und Matthias fürs Mitmachen und Erzählen, was Amateurfunk so ist, bei den Show Notes, die während der Sendung die Show Notes geschrieben haben, bei Danimo, der sich um die ganze Technik gekümmert hat. Dann bleibt mir nur noch zu sagen, vielen Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt beim Chaosradio 224. Die nächste Ausgabe gibt es dann wieder von Fritz aus Potsdam. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter, mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.